mom I'm going to a wedding
could have been anyway
Grace killed them both
I was surprised at how quickly they were
able to solve all the little puzzles
last season and people would freeze
frame and re-watch it's on the party
that's what season two is all about it
all adds up to something I didn't catch
on to any of the puzzles except for when
they did something it's nothing nasty
seeing the forums that sprung up 10
minutes after an episode came out they
would have found the puzzle solve the
puzzle and then be arguing about it
press input
if you're a casual viewer you shouldn't
be able to figure it out easily oh
but the clues are there there's clues in
the words there's in the paintings
there's so many Clues not a difficult
puzzle to solve Chris came to us and
said I want to add a bunch of other
layers what can we put on the wall what
can we have people saying what can we
have people wearing an after party one
it was one puzzle per episode there are
more puzzles this season and they are
far more difficult than hiding two
things in every episode what can we put
on each table that might be puzzles I
gotta walk this off it was Gauntlet
Throne this season to have even more
twists and even more puzzles let's have
some fun
that's the trick have a mystery that's
engaging or people who are just casually
watching and the people who are really
intensely watching after partying
[Applause]
all the secrets are coming out time to
get a squishy